in what I think is a hilarious but also
correct turn of events Roseanne bars
reboot of her sitcom Roseanne has been
canceled by ABC just hours after she
tweeted just a horribly racist string of
messages Roseanne posted a comment
yesterday it feels like it's a week ago
because of how much has happened but
yesterday Roseanne posted a comment
about former Obama advisor Valerie
Valerie Jarrett on Twitter saying Muslim
Brotherhood and Planet of the Apes had a
baby equals VJ meaning Valerie Jarrett
in response to another Twitter comment
about Valerie Jarrett and of course
Valerie Jarrett happens to be black and
Roseanne references monkeys and as usual
her defenders say it's not racist monkey
isn't racist Planet of the Apes isn't
racist it's merely a coincidence that
Valerie Valerie Jarrett is black and
historically there is significant sort
of racist institutional history of
equating black people to monkeys but
it's a mere coincidence and of course
why are the people that are insulted as
monkeys very often black are they saying
it is literally the mere coincidence I'm
sarcastically referencing and Roseanne
later deleted the tweet but it was too
late just hours later ABC cancelled
Roseanne's show they put out a statement
which said in part that quote Rosen's
Twitter statement is abhorrent repugnant
and inconsistent with our values and we
have decided to cancel her show Roseanne
also later apologizing on Twitter saying
I apologized to Valerie Jarrett and to
all Americans I am truly sorry for
making a bad joke about her politics and
her looks I should have known better
forgive me my joke was in bad taste that
was the one of the first apologies later
she said she was tweeting on the sleep
medication ambien saying it was 2:00 in
the morning and I was ambien tweeting it
was Memorial Day too
I don't know how Memorial Day brings out
racist statement when you are on ambien
or what the connection a connection is
and of course obviously my question was
did AM B is she saying ambien made her
racist I mean I've taken ambien
when I'm traveling to try to adjust very
difficult to fall asleep with the jetlag
when you go to Europe for example I
didn't all of a sudden think black
people were monkeys nor nor did it occur
to me to start tweeting about it and it
is just fascinating for a few reasons
first of all and I'll get to I know that
people are aware that she has blocked me
because of my comments we'll get to that
in a second Roseanne's reboot made her
like a darling of the right
it was rebooted it initially got great
ratings Trump called roseanne to
congratulate her the right hail that is
finally a show just for sort of regular
traditional people despite the fact that
Roseanne is super rich and part Jewish
not the sort of down-home whatever she's
made out to be a good old gal or
whatever let's put that aside and this
has completely imploded in their faces
and I tweeted her about this I've
actually exchanged direct messages and
tweets with Roseanne before I tweeted to
Roseanne after the ambien thing which
we'll put up on the screen for you oh
man this is just the best Roseanne is
now defending her tweets by saying
ambien made her racist and Roseanne
almost immediately responding to me
saying no I didn't I blamed myself
stop lying yes I have had odd ambien
experiences on tweeting late at night
like many other people do I blame myself
okay it's just an explanation not an
excuse okay bully and then when I went
to respond she had sadly blocked me
Roseanne I don't even know where to
start with this right I mean politically
this is a woman who's off her rocker
right she has called Chelsea Clinton
Chelsea Soros Clinton she said George
Soros is trying to overthrow the US
government and she said that the CIA is
funding some kind of mind-control thing
all of this really really crazy stuff
but what I don't really understand here
is if you're not blaming ambien why do
you mention ambien and if the ambien had
a role to play did the ambien make you
think racist things that you wouldn't
normally
we think or did the ambien merely lower
your inhibitions to the point where you
were willing to tweet the racist things
that you always think it's like when Mel
Gibson was pulled over that time and he
was immediately going on unprovoked
anti-semitic rants and he said the
problem was that he was drunk and of
course the question is is he saying
alcohol makes you anti-semitic or it
merely makes you willing to say the
anti-semitic things that you always
think for what it's worth the
manufacturer of ambien has put out a
statement saying that racism is not a
known side effect of ambien so so we've
heard that and I you know I don't know
is there more to say pat about my
exchange with her or is that it is that
basically all we need to say well it's
interesting that she says that you're a
bully hours after calling Valerie
Jarrett a mix between the Planet of the
Apes and the Muslim Brotherhood I mean
can't really make that argument in that
case yeah I don't really have a
reputation for bullying people but okay
that's what she chose to say to me let's
talk about sort of the firing and the
implications here I want to put up an
assessment that is 100% a similar to
mine and it's from another none other
than Dave Rubin who at one point was
using Roseanne's studio for his show
Dave Rubin tweeted yesterday Roseanne
exercised her free speech and ABC
decided to end their free association
now it's on you to either support her or
not boycott ABC or not or share your own
opinion as a free person or not once
again freedom is messy but it's better
than the alternative
and I agree in a sense it's not about
free speech at all and that there's no
question or concern at all about free
speech or censorship here right Rosen
said outrageous things and her employer
fired her period she doesn't need the
money she's worth like 80 million
dollars and my only real concern is that
she has really messed things up for the
entire production staff at ABC right the
people running the cameras the people
doing the tech work they don't have 80
million dollars like Rosanna do they
lose their jobs now because of Rosen's
racist tweet hopefully some of those
employees are part of a union and maybe
our guaranteed money for the first
season or whatever no matter whether the
show is canceled or not
hopefully I I don't really know the
answer to that
and of course Donald Trump I don't even
know that we're not gonna put it up on
the screen to trump did say something
about how he never received a call from
Bob Iger from ABC when ABC criticized
him but Bob Iger called Valerie Jarrett
or something like that the only
surprising thing about any of this is
that anybody was surprised by it because
of Roseanne's very very long history of
tweeting bizarre and depraved conspiracy
theories and generally just insulting
things but I think it was a big win in
the battle of ideas Pat I mean listen
everybody got to say what they wanted to
say a corporation was able to make the
business decision that they felt was
right for them government didn't
interfere period right I mean a major
win in the battle of the free exchange
of ideas yeah everything worked out okay
I guess I'm just surprised ABC decided
to have her back on to reboot the sitcom
knowing that Roseanne has a history of
doing this saying racist things on
Twitter she actually made a very similar
remark about Susan Rice another former
Obama official and another black woman
comparing hurts who will monkey as well
yes so you know they could have
preempted some of this at least it's
like it's not like this is a new thing
for Mose Ann that's why I'm not going
around patting ABC on the back saying
wow they've they've just done this
amazing thing they made a business
decision it is a that is exactly what it
is if this were good for business if
people weren't outraged but they said
you know what it's so great that
someone's finally out there saying that
valerie jarrett is like a monkey in some
way they wouldn't have fired her right
they would have said hey Roseanne said
what she wanted to say on her Twitter we
employ her to produce the Roseanne show
or act in the Roseanne show whatever
this is merely all about optics and
you're right Pat which is that this is
not shocking this is another one in a
long history of these types of comments
from Roseanne so I think that the the
decision made by ABC was the right one
although they made it for business
decisions not from not for business
reasons not for moral or ethical reasons
and that's completely something that
they can do send me your thoughts about
the entire Roseanne thing I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman and the show is on Twitter
at David Pakman show things are starting
to get really bad for Donald Trump jr.
the FBI now has secret wiretaps
Spanish police of a conversation between
Alexander tortion who's an official of
Russia's central bank who we've
discussed before because he was part of
that story involving Russia funneling
money through the NRA to the Trump
campaign and these wiretaps that the FBI
has reportedly led to a meeting between
Donald Trump jr. and Alexander tortion
oh lordy there are tapes at least some
of them and Jose Grenda who has been
investigating Spanish organized crime
for a very long time was asked about
whether there's concern that tortion had
meetings with Donald Trump jr. and
Grenda said quote mr. Trump's son should
be concerned and this is now starting to
get beyond anything we could call
innocent coincidences the lead Russian
guy who was revealed by the McClatchy
investigation which we interviewed
vivica Nova Novack about as being a
primary player in the funneling of
Russian funds to the Trump campaign
through the NRA which of course would be
against the law met with Donald Trump
jr. and there are wiretaps related to
that meeting that tortion had with Trump
jr.
so let's go through it layer by layer
number one the fact that the FBI has
these wiretaps implies tortion is of
interest to the FBI which means that any
combination of the meeting with Trump
jr. to the funneling of money through
the NRA might now be part of Robert
Moeller's investigation number two
Spain is now involved with this and is
cooperating with the FBI that's another
indication as to the size and scope of
this entire thing number three the idea
that this entire Muller investigation is
almost over who believes that when Spain
just entered the proceedings over the
last couple of months very difficult to
believe
and then lastly how far have the goal
posts moved right at some point and it
seems like ancient history at this point
the Trump campaign said no one in the
campaign had any contact with Russians
it seems hilarious to even think back to
that at this point Jeff Sessions said it
and Donald Trump said it and everybody
said it
who's even talking about that is the
standard anymore the discussion now is
what of the contact was criminal if any
was there obstruction to try to hide
that contact we never met with Russians
became there were meanings but they
weren't about anything - there were
meetings about helping our campaign but
they never actually did end up helping
the campaign and now it's becoming hey
listen there was all sorts of stuff
going on but none of it was actually
against the law
and if it was Hillary would have done
the exact same thing anyway or she
already did and then the last point I
want to make about this is Jose Grenda
the Spanish investigator saying that
Trump jr. should be concerned
Jose Grenda has been a major
investigator in Spain of organized crime
he's not a guy that you want to mess
with he's made his career investigating
organized crime and corruption in Spain
he's saying merely on the basis of what
he has found that Donald Trump jr.
should be worried the response from
trumpets they always have one here it is
deep state right I mean deep state if
ever there was proof that there was an
international conspiracy to take down
Donald Trump over nothing more than a
witch-hunt it's that now even the
Spanish are involved so obviously it's a
deep state conspiracy that we need to
expose here stunning that this is going
on and this isn't even the only story
from the weekend like this we also
learned during our long weekend that
days before his inauguration in January
of 2017
Donald Trump's personal lawyer well days
before Trump's inauguration Trump's
personal lawyer Michael Cohen met with
another Russian at Trump Tower so that's
gonna have to be a story for another day
maybe but I think what's clear is that
this was supposed to be over by last
Thanksgiving if you believe these people
clearly it's not going to be over
anytime soon I've been really struggling
with whether or not I should be calling
this story Trump cocked by Korean
leaders because we've talked about how
use of the term [ __ ] by us is obviously
completely satirical it's making a joke
out of how the right uses the word but
it still arguably might be better
not to use the word even as a joke right
because it's mere use could suggest that
it has a legitimate place in political
vocabulary and and I don't think that it
does so I've said it once and we'll
simply say from now on that Trump has
been yet again embarrassed by his total
failure on the North Korean summit last
week we learned totally not surprisingly
that the Trump North Korea summit was
canceled and it was canceled as it was
becoming more and more clear that it
just wasn't going to go the way that
Donald Trump wanted and of course any
fool would have known that months ago
and then over the long weekend we
learned that it's possible that the
summit might be back on but if it is it
would be the result at least partially
of a kim jeong-hoon moon jae-in North
South Korean respective leaders surprise
summit the second one between the North
and South Korean leaders and very
clearly if there is going to be any real
sort of substantive advancement with the
North Korea situation it's moon jae-in
who has been doing the real work here
and we don't know the full
subject-matter of the talks that they
had yet but what we do know is that one
of the topics was reinstating the summit
which with Donald Trump which Trump
canceled last week and the White House
did confirm according to Sarah Huckabee
Sanders that the summit might be back on
and yet again moon jae-in a professional
diplomat who would be responsible in
great part for the summit being back on
Donald Trump tweeting we are having very
productive talks with North Korea about
reinstating the summit which if it does
happen will likely remain in Singapore
on the same date June 12th and if
necessary will be extended beyond that
date do you think that Trump realizes
that the dynamic is that he's the sort
of childish buffoon who understands
nothing and just digs this hole and then
in comes moon jae-in as the adult in the
room to clean up Trump's mess and people
are taking this totally cartoonish and
bogus sort of point of view about Trump
getting a Nobel Peace Prize if this
happens
if this happens it will be despite Trump
not because of him and if anybody here
would get a medal of any kind wouldn't
it obviously be the South Korean
president moon J and I actually read
online one of the funniest sort of post
hoc rationalizations of why Trump really
is the hero here and the argument I'm
you'll have to excuse that I'm not able
to super eloquently summarize some of
these trumpets right arguments but the
argument as I understood it was Trump
canceled the original summit
specifically to allow for the second
secret summit and moon jae-in coming in
and sort of playing the good cop to then
set kim jeong-hoon
up to go to the rescheduled summit with
trump more ready to negotiate or
something like that like it's a
completely impossible to disprove
hypothesis and and all along that sort
of been the case right the idea that
trumps tweets are really what put this
thing in motion
if you believe that there's really no
conversation for us to have watching Fox
and Friends and tweeting is the real
hard work of the North Korea summit and
moon jae-in is the guy who's the puppet
or the placeholder I mean we're just not
going to be able to have any really
substantive conversations with people
who believe that but a very slight sort
of reframing exposes this as Trump the
great negotiator sitting at home
canceling the talks while moon jae-in
actually gets things done and I think
that that's that's the most accurate
point of view here and this actually
carries some risk the the entire
exclusion of Trump if indeed Trump is
going to be excluded and moon jae-in
making progress with Kim jong-un
actually carries a lot of political risk
because we know Trump right and on
principle alone I can imagine a
situation where the North and the South
negotiate something they come to some
kind of agreement right and Trump says
he's not going to support it he's not
going to be part of it the United States
is not going to be part of it because
Trump wasn't part of the negotiation and
his ego and his narcissism would no
doubt make it possible that he would do
that so I actually think that the the
best path forward is
we all know that moon jaein is doing the
work here we all know that it will be
American in South Korean career
diplomats who were doing the work here
it might be a good idea to keep Trump
involved at least on paper to placate
him and make him believe that he did a
big boy and that he's going to get a
reward because I think otherwise there's
a good chance that he says I I'd listen
I wasn't involved in this
maybe we're not gonna be part of this
thing whatsoever yeah well I think moon
jae-in has been doing an excellent job
because he'll occasionally credit Donald
Trump he complements them he can't
really it's just a way to keep Trump out
of it that way he doesn't have to send
out those little rocket man tweets
anymore and moon jae-in and Kim Jong
moon can actually get some progress done
yeah I when I see moon jae-in talk about
you know any anything positive about
Trump's involvement in this it seems
like it is sort of that placating of
Trump that I'm suggesting is somewhat of
a good idea so we'll see what ultimately
happens I guess maybe the summit is back
on possibly we don't really know at this
point but maybe by tomorrow at this time
we will Fox News host Shepard Smith
completely dismantled Donald Trump's spy
gate lies yesterday and this Friday on
audience questions we're gonna cover
what would it take for Fox News to turn
on Donald Trump and when we say that we
mean aside from the occasional voices of
reason of Shep Smith less frequently
Chris Wallace and one time I was it just
one time Neil Cavuto I think it was one
time that Neil Cavuto said something
that made sense
one thing that Shep Smith has been doing
throughout the trump presidency more
than anybody else on Fox News has been
calling out Donald Trump for his lies
and that includes the Hillary Clinton
uranium one conspiracy theory a few
months ago and he did it again yesterday
and if you haven't been following
Spygate and i don't blame you if you
haven't been following it it's a sort of
amalgamation of conspiracy theories
being pushed by Trump and Rudy Giuliani
and some others ranging from Democrats
and Robert Muller are rigging the
upcoming midterms to literally there was
an FBI spy in Donald Trump's campaign
during 2016 and it's all meant to
discredit Robert Moeller's investigation
Trump yesterday sent out an early
morning tweet about some of the stuff
saying the 13 angry Democrats Plus
people who work eight year
for Obama working on the rigged Russia
witch-hunt
we'll be meddling with the midterm
elections especially now that
Republicans stay tough are taking the
lead in polls polls capitalized
there was no collusion collusion
capitalized except by the Democrats this
is not only ridiculous but indicative of
a completely expired relationship to the
real world on the behalf of Donald Trump
Shep Smith dismantling the entire thing
on Fox News no less take a look
president Trump accusing his special
counsel and his team of a whole new set
of conspiracy theories unfounded not
based in fact or reason with no evidence
to support them
the president says backup the president
says that Robert Muller and his team are
meddling in the midterms there's nothing
to support that claim and neither the
president nor the White House has
offered anything to support that claim
yet here's the tweet right the 13 angry
Democrats plus people who worked eight
years for Obama working on the rigged
Russia witch-hunt will be meddling with
the midterm elections especially now
that Republicans stay tough are taught
are taking the lead in the polls hidden
flexure was no collusion except by the
Democrats that was the tweet the
president claims the special counsel
investigating Russia
election interference and potential
collusion with team Trump will be
meddling in our elections there is
nothing to indicate that's true as for
the rest of the tweet documents show
there are people who've registered as
Democrats on the special counsels team
but Robert Muller is a Republican and so
is president Trump's Deputy Attorney
General rod Rosen Stein who appointed
Muller an appointment many top
Republicans praised and the so-called
rigged Russia witch-hunt is not a
witch-hunt it has resulted in charges
against for former Trump associates
three pleaded guilty to lying to
investigators about Russia President
Trump has also claimed the fed spied on
his campaign with an informant the
president calls it spy gate Fox News can
confirm it is not Fox News knows of no
evidence to support the president's
claim that lawmaker
from both parties say using an informant
to investigate a suspected ties to
Russia is not spying it's part of the
normal investigative process I truly
don't know why Shep is on Fox News and
we've speculated that it's calculated by
Fox so that when they get called out for
their sweeping bias they can say well
look we've got Shep Smith here it's
possible Shep Smith has something on the
executives there the late great Alan
Combs who of course passed away a couple
years ago is someone I got a chance to
know sort of well when I was living in
New York City and he told me some
interesting things about Shep Smith
which I've never discussed but would not
make me totally surprised that Shep
Smith may actually have something on Fox
executives there many possibilities and
I genuinely wonder whether having Shep
on Fox News is a good thing overall
right because on the one hand we could
say listen Shep Smith on Fox is an
attempt to pierce the hyper partisan
bubble that their viewers live in the
counter to that would be isn't it sort
of a waste of someone who can tell it as
it is at least sometimes and all it
really provides is some cover for Fox
News to say here's one guy who has a
different point of view which is called
the facts compared to everybody else on
Fox News so I don't know do you have a
strong feeling one way or the other Pat
about whether it's a net gain or loss to
have Shep on Fox I think it's a net gain
for Fox to have him on because yeah then
they can say that we play at both sides
but it's pretty obvious too that they're
never gonna put him in primetime they're
not they're not gonna mix them in with
like Hannity and Laura Ingraham and
Carlson he'll keep him his show in the
early afternoon and and that satisfies
everyone I think and the Fox News
audience still immediately calls for his
firing every time he says something like
this so it doesn't seem like he's really
getting through to too many people over
there in any case he was right there's
no evidence whatsoever that any of these
conspiracy theories are actually based
in reality there is just total chaos in
Italy right now and don't worry I'm
going to talk about Roseanne Barr losing
it on me on Twitter but that's coming a
little later in the show some
international news I want to start with
today what's happening in Italy is
having repercussions not only in all of
Europe but also in the United States and
if you've not been following what's
taken place in Italy
Italy's bigger party the
five star movement as well as the very
extreme far-right league party won more
than half of the votes in the
parliamentary elections that were held a
couple months ago in March and together
they selected Paulo Savona to become the
economic minister hugely anti euro guy
even though being against the euro
wasn't made a major part of either of
those party's campaigns and the
far-right party coalition all of a
sudden having this position of
significant power within Italy has
thrown the broader government into
crisis
so what then happened is that Italian
president sergio mattarella block the
formation of the government straight up
vetoed it and has asked for a temporary
government to be formed but both the
five star movement and League party
objected to the choice made by
mattarella
not surprisingly and this is the
equivalent of a sort of constitutional
crisis that's taking place in Italy
right now the Euro crashed on the news
stocks yesterday in the u.s. falling
significantly major market decline
happening here and the increased fears
of political uncertainty could go so far
as even in the United States to upend
the Federal Reserve's plan for continued
rate increases which we won't go into
detail about today but I have spoken
quite a bit about what those rate
increases sort of means signify and what
the consequences of those rate increases
can be and what's taking place in Europe
generally is often very easy for us to
ignore here in the United States sort of
out of sight out of mind but it is of
massive proportions not only are we
seeing the right of the the rise of
these far-right parties in many European
countries which at its face is very
concerning because these are really
really vile movements it's also a big
sort of economic uncertainty because if
any of the strong anti EU and sort of
anti euro views become empowered in a
significant way within the European
context that is going to have a signal
an impact and if indeed these new
elections happen in Italy in July it
will in a way be a referendum on the
euro itself and that's really not good
for financial stability and there are
numerous critiques to be made of the
European Union there are absolutely
concerns about the euro as a currency
but the broader sort of turbulent
circumstances that will be precipitated
by this should be something that we're
all worried about and there are concerns
in many countries right if you look at
Germany Angela Merkel the Chancellor has
to form a government after seeing a
significant far-right surge during her
last election in Spain there might be a
no confidence vote as early as this week
and maybe new elections there and I've
been touch with it been in touch with
the parts of my family that live in
Spain and it is incredibly tumultuous
there as well and the most interesting
aspect of this in relation to the United
States isn't just that it's causing our
stock markets to be turbulent right we
know how the stock market only effects
disproportionately the rich although
there's lots of people that hold some
amount of stocks but for me the most
interesting element here is that the
same right-wing sort of version of
populism maybe it's a perversion of
populism or a version of populism that
Donald Trump capitalized on is similar
to what's happening in many European
countries it's an often less sort of
ignorant version of right-wing populism
slightly less ignorant I don't want to
overstate that
but it's the populist sounding
authoritarian nationalism that is
underlying both America first and our
currency first right be not the euro
mentality that we're seeing in some
enclaves in Europe it's the same
immigrants out mentality under Trump in
the United States to the immigrants out
mentality in Europe although very often
the European far-right contingents are
able to couch it in a seemingly sort of
more eloquent sounding way but many of
the same themes are the backbone here I
don't know ultimately what is going to
happen in Europe but of course we're
gonna be following it very
very closely is rudy guiliani secretly
secretly working for robert muller i'm
not actually suggesting that he is in in
a serious manner but since Rudy Guiliani
has joined Donald Trump's legal team it
has been just like one faceplant after
another that are really not making
Donald Trump look good not that he
looked great before Rudy joined his team
first Giuliani joined Trump's legal team
and immediately did an interview where
he admitted that actually yeah Trump did
repay Michael Cohen a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars in stormy Daniels hush
money after countless denials from Trump
in the White House and everybody else
then Rudy Giuliani in another interview
that was just very strange tried to walk
back his own claim by saying things he
says are just rumors basically writing
off his own assertions as just rumors
that he had heard then Rudy Giuliani
comes out and makes the very strange
statement after the conviction of
Michael Cohen's business partner of Gani
Friedman that he meaning Giuliani
himself has as much to do with New York
City taxis as Michael Cohen had to do
with New York City taxes which is insane
since Michael Cohen actually had a lot
to do with New York City taxes and then
last week I told you about this
absolutely outrageous interview that
Rudy Giuliani did where he said that
Donald Trump was at risk of committing
perjury if interviewed by Robert Moeller
not because Trump would be lying but
because the truth is relative and almost
like postmodernist critique of the
Moller investigation not exactly what I
would expect from a lawyer for Donald
Trump and now the latest and I'm gonna
play some clips for you today is that
Rudy Giuliani appeared on CNN and just
made no sense and I'm not saying he made
no sense in some symbolic way he
literally made no sense like I didn't
know what he was talking about during
this interview here he is asked by Dana
Bash about whether this whole Spygate
thing which we haven't even talked about
because it's so crazy whether the entire
Spygate thing is an attempt to just
interfere with robert Moeller's
investigation I cannot understand Rudy
Giuliani's answer take a listen
let's start right there the the FBI
confidential source is directly
connected to this ongoing investigation
into the president's campaign doesn't it
create an appearance that the White
House is interfering with this
investigation
I don't see that Dana I think that the
White House has every right to know the
president has every right to know as
commander-in-chief
after all the investigation as the
Democrat said revealed nothing new so
there's nothing to us that means
exculpatory because the new would be if
something turned up that was a that was
a surprise huh so it should be very easy
to brief us and we can come out of it
saying same thing nothing new or we
might come out and be able to say
nothing in which case you'll have a real
signal what is he talking about look I
don't understand what he's talking about
it he seems confused and sort of slow
and this went on for 20 minutes here's
another section where Rudy Giuliani's
answer is so inconvenient incoherent
that Dan abash changes topic altogether
to is trump gonna sit down with robert
muller because she doesn't know what
he's talking about and if you're
watching you'll notice that when she
asks will trump sit down with Moeller
rudy giuliani's eyes bug out as she
asked the question and then of course
totally incoherent answer but if it is
true and it's dangerous to this man he
better be protected already I don't
believe he's being protected says to me
that maybe the FBI and the Justice
Department it's being a little
hypocritical here why is that well they
said he can't be revealed because it's
dangerous now he's been revealed Wall
Street Journal several other newspapers
if that man is demand
he better be protected I'm not sure but
I hear he's not so what's going on mr.
mayor I want to just ask point-blank
will the president sit down with Robert
Muller even if the White House legal
team or you anybody on his legal legal
team doesn't get a briefing about this
confidential source well if he wasn't
thinking about it and it wasn't an
active possibility we'd be finished with
that by now we've moved on then they get
to hey Rudy
you keep talking about the entire
investigation being rigged how is any of
this rigged and here is Rudy Giuliani's
answer it's rigged I just want to go
through because I know you use this this
term a lot and obviously so does the
president this investigation has already
brought charges against 22 people and
entities including 13 Russians who have
been indicted for trying to change the
the outcome of the election so how is it
a rigged investigation when they already
when they're not even close to being
done and they already have this in their
pocket well because first of all the two
different vestigation right the
counterintelligence investigation is now
over for over a year and they weren't
disclosing it to anybody immediately
that raises questions in my mind why not
I think why not because it clears the
present then you get the Comey thing
which is a leak of a confidential memo
which is illegal for an FBI official to
do it and that becomes the basis for
appointing Muller
I'm not saying well the problem is the
leak the problem is the leak it's kind
of sad isn't it pat like what the hell
is Rudy Giuliani talking about here and
he was a very good prosecutor he was
involved in some interesting mob cases
related to Donnie Brasco he had a lot of
policies as New York City mayor that I
disagreed with but he was sort of a
normal mayor he did some measurably good
things in New York City what is the guy
talking about here he also in this
interview admitted that the Spygate
thing was just a PR ploy right I think
you know to quote Donald Trump from a
couple of weeks ago he just joined
Trump's legal team he needs to go back
and read over his notes and think about
you know what the story is right you
inform himself before he can be doing
interviews and yeah Pat's pointing out
what the entire point of all of this
Spygate stuff is which is just try to
discredit Mulder by pushing Spygate the
idea that there's like some kind of
organized there was an organized spy in
the Trump campaign being handled by the
FBI or something along those lines
Giuliani has been a disaster for Trump
since he was hired and these are the
behaviors of someone who knows that
their client is in trouble right it's
all a discredited witch-hunt
Moeller can't be trusted Trump can't
talk to Mulder because the truth is
relative there could be a perjury trap
and Spygate makes the entire thing
element as opposed to let's all get
together as adults and clear this up so
that the president can get back to
focusing on just being the president and
unfortunately the problem is that as
disastrous as Rudy Giuliani has been
when it comes to the truth
Trump won the election by lying and
there's a lot that line can achieve for
a candidate like Trump with a cult of
personality around him the way he has so
Rudy Giuliani can probably do a lot of
good by going out and lying as well
hopefully Muller is not going to be
distracted by it but the PR war can be
very positively impacted by having
somebody like Rudy go out and just tell
lies send me your thoughts if you
understood this interview I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman and the show is on Twitter
at David Pakman show
for a guy who said that Hillary Clinton
couldn't be trusted with sensitive
secret and classified information Donald
Trump is being really careless with
classified information and at a recent
fundraiser Trump bragged to donors in
the room about a classified battle that
took place in Syria and this was again I
want to restate that that word this was
a classified event the White House has
avoided talking about it it involves US
and Russian connected troops or
mercenaries in Syria last week Donald
Trump held the dinner fundraiser in
Manhattan it was fifty thousand dollars
per person and Trump said that he was
just so impressed by the performance of
the f-18 fighters it was just amazing
that they did ten minutes of strikes and
took out 100 to 300 Russians which now
we sort of have gotten a little more
information they may be Russian Syrian
connected mercenaries it's unclear
exactly what everybody's background is
but none of this had been previously
reported it's all classified and all of
a sudden the transparency trolls Kruk
come out of the woodwork and they say
hey this is good we want to know what
our government is doing and I agree with
them but by Trump's own standards one of
the primary disqualifiers for being
president is being careless with
classified information Hillary Clinton
supposedly was not a good candidate for
president because she was careless with
classified information that's exactly
what Donald Trump is doing here and the
the sort of height of the comedy of
errors that this is
White House deputy press secretary Raja
was asked hey trump spilled classified
information at this fundraiser Raj Shah
said I can't talk about that because the
contents of it are classified right how
brilliant is that it is sitcom level
stupid we might call it Roseanne level
stupid isn't anybody who voted for Trump
scared that the guy with the nuclear
codes is spilling classified information
to Russians in the Oval Office to a
roomful of donors I would guess that
he's spilling classified information to
Sean Hannity during their nightly phone
calls during which Sean Hannity puts
Trump to bed and actually got an email
from a viewer saying David you know in a
way we should be glad that Trump is this
dominant competent because sometimes
having a little bit of a clue is
dangerous and if Trump had a little bit
more knowledge he might already have
gotten us into something like george w
bush's Iraq war sort of the idea that
total incompetence is better than slight
incompetence with a clue and some really
really bad ideas and george w bush came
off as really dumb but he had some ideas
horrible hawkish neoconservative ideas
and he acted on them Trump likes to act
super smart but he truly knows nothing
and it might it just might keep him from
doing even more horrible things so I
don't I don't know what what else to say
about the specifics of this incident
Trump's talking about the deaths of 100
to 300 Russians were not at war with
Russia it's possible that these are
mercenaries of Russian nationality who
are just in Syria on their own but even
like the subject matter here Pat is
incredibly disturbing massive military
power killing one to three hundred
people in Syria well the bottom line is
that the president can declassify
whatever he wants right that's what the
Trump is used as an excuse when he
spilled secrets to the Russians in the
Oval Office sure but you'd like to think
that it would be done for some greater
purpose right like the president has the
American people's best interests at
heart
no Trump is just doing it for a
punchline or to brag I mean there's no
greater purpose there yeah the people in
the room had already paid the fifty
great
right so did they really need to hear
about the classified thing that the
United States did and actually the the
one thing I will say is I'm not a
hypocrite on the source of the leak
versus the content of the leak Trump was
completely irresponsible in what he said
now that he said it we should look into
what happened there because 100 to 300
Russian serious mercenaries dying with
supposedly one American ending up
wounded in what is a huge military
offensive given what we thought was
going on in Syria it's actually really
disturbing in terms of what it is that
Donald Trump is doing and what took
place there so now that the cat is out
of the bag we should look into it
immediately